before creation itself there were six
singularities forged into Infinity
stones hey everybody its charlie
hopefully you've had a chance to see
infinity war once or twice by now
this is gonna be my video explaining how
the soul gem works and why the Thanos
theory you know th a NOS theory ended up
being correct just not in the way that
everyone expected so obviously spoiler
warning if you haven't seen infinity war
yet there's a new round of the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway too that I'll explain
at the end of the video most of you are
probably familiar with it but if you've
never heard of the Thanos theory of the
location of the Infinity stones that was
mostly what it referred to like where
the stones popped up it started to
percolate after phase two after we had
seen a couple of stones people like wait
a minute
t for tesseract a for aether and for
necklace of the time stone o for the orb
of the Power Stone s for the scepter of
the mine stone so for the longest time
people were wondering what H meant and
this theory actually started before dr.
strange so we didn't know that n was
necklace people were like wait a minute
the Marvel movies are continuing to
verify this theory so everyone was just
expecting that H would pan out as
something like Heimdall
but after thor ragnarok it was confirmed
no soul gem anywhere to be found
we got the Black Panther and people were
like okay wait a minute maybe it's gonna
be heart-shaped or maybe it's gonna be
the heart tree of Wakanda then Ryan
Coogler came out and was like I love the
Infinity stones he's a huge lifelong
comic book fan just like James Gunn but
he was like we already had vibranium we
felt like that was special enough so
obviously for Infinity Ward they
fabricated a completely new backstory
for the soul stone in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to make it part of
the emotional through line for Thanos as
part of that big twist with Gamora to
prove that Thanos wasn't just a mustache
twirling villain he was capable of
loving something they wanted to make you
feel that sacrifice in the price that he
would pay so we'll get to the mechanics
of the soul stone in a second because
it's a big hat tip for what's going to
be happening during Avengers 4 a
sacrifice that the Avengers will
eventually have to make to wield it but
if you're not a big comic book reader
the powers of the soul stone
have to do with controlling souls as the
name implies pretty easy slam dunk there
it allows the person who wields it to
capture the souls of people preserving
life after death that's a really
important idea it also has the ability
to devolve living beings which is where
you get to the ash people at the end of
infinity war so when people are turning
to ash
that's Thanos using the powers of the
soul stone amplified when used in
conjunction with the power stone the
space stone the reality stone in the
Mayan stone so remember there's a
stacking bonus from using the stones
together so for instance he uses the
time stone to turn vision back so that
he can take the mine stone from him
before he exploded but Thanos could
actually roll time back or forwards for
the entire universe if he used the time
stone with all the other stones together
so we know there's a lot of separate
questions about how the Avengers are
going to fix everything and bring all
those ash people back because I do think
that all the ash people will come back I
just don't think it's gonna be the way
that people expect but even though the
stone was on Vermeer the reason why the
Thanos theory is still correct there's
actually three reasons why it's still
correct one the planet for me or where
they find it is inside the hel gent our
system which is inside Kree controlled
space remember that for Red Skull stuff
Avengers for Captain Marvel
that'll come back around later when we
talk about the history of red skull
after he got ported into space by the
space stone like what was he doing that
whole time he said he was searching for
stones Ian's a part of the galaxy where
Captain Marvel is popping up but number
two you could also say that H stands for
Hydra since Red Skull is the guardian of
the soul stone they're sort of combining
a couple different ideas here when he
pops up because he's meant to represent
the aspect of death but he's also the
guardian of the soul stone as if the
soul stone captured his soul and he's
now prisoner to it but if you were
wondering ladie death doesn't appear
anywhere in the Infinity war movie they
confirmed that last week before the
movie came out they're like we didn't
use her as a character so Red Skull is
the closest thing that you get to the
aspect of death but the age of the
Thanos Theory also applies to the
mechanics of the soul gem in the price
that you have to pay you have to give
your heart to it so to speak like fan
OHS has to give something
he loves something that he cares about
trading a soul for a soul remember
there's a big Avengers line we don't
trade lives that'll come back around
during Avengers for it too but they
knows trades at Gamora soul in order to
wield it which is why at the end of the
movie when he goes into that special
place I think that that is the soul
world Gamora will come back during
Avengers 4 even though it seems like she
died like they wanted that big emotional
moment they wanted you to feel it so
they're not gonna talk about it for a
long time but the actress Zoe Saldana
did an interview where she said she was
going back to film scenes for Avengers 4
can you tell us if your infinity war in
the middle of it I think that the
Guardians just shot their part when it
comes to infinity Wars like the first
part and we all have to go back for
gauntlets
later this year most people saw that and
they were thinking more about what the
title of Avengers 4 would be not the
fact that she would have died during
Avengers 3 but still come back during
Avengers 4 so two reasons why that
interview is important but when red
skull tells Thanos that there's a
certain wisdom that comes with wielding
the soul stone
properly he's talking about the price
you have to pay like when little Gamora
asks him inside the soul world did you
do it was it worth the price he looks at
her sadly and says yes little one I
don't think he totally understands where
he is he might comprehend it but think
about it this way the soul world
contains the souls of certain people now
it might contain the souls of all the
ashed people - that was an immediately
evident from that Thanos scene but it is
a logical explanation and it is how the
gem works in the comics so you can use
some of the comic book explainer but
obviously they've changed the plot of
the comics quite a bit but what happens
when someone tries to wield the gauntlet
incorrectly so the stones work together
but in order to wield the soul stone you
have to sacrifice something you love you
have to feed it a soul so what if
somebody just put the gauntlet on and
tried to fix everything usually what
happens in the comics is is either one
of the stones will crack it'll break
like it'll kind of melt it at the end of
Infinity Ward not completely broken but
it looks like Thanos is gonna have to
wait a little while before he uses it
again but also the stones can scatter
themselves across the cosmos but here's
where we get into Avengers for territory
how do the Avengers fix
everything do they go back in time do
they just use the gauntlet to wish
everything back because you could do
that too
but the problem now is that the gauntlet
looks like it's damaged and I've talked
about why I think that Ironman is gonna
be the one to wear the gauntlet just
because of that parallel arc that they
put him in Thanos on he respects him
Captain America is somebody who's also
worn the gauntlet in the comics
spider-man has even had the gauntlet but
he's been turned to ash so he's probably
not gonna be a really big character
during adventures for think about who's
still alive at the end of the movie and
who had the most emotional moments with
Thanos
aside from Gamora so Iron Man probably
had the biggest scene with him there
were a couple really important gem
related scenes during infinity war one
there was Shuri examining the power of
the mine stone she did some work but
obviously she didn't finish with vision
he ended up dying anyway
that'll come back around there are a
couple of characters like ant-man and
the wasp they're gonna be going into the
quantum realm during their movie what
can you do with the Infinity stones you
could actually travel inside them so
when they come back their powers will
also be useful for examining what's
going on inside the gems then there's
the way the movie leaves Thanos at the
end of Avengers 4 because even if his
arc is done you have to have some way to
wrap him up so that he's not a loose
thread just traveling through the galaxy
if he's alive at the end of Avengers 4
he could always be a threat and come
back so you have to resolve that in some
way the easiest way to deal with him is
to trap him for all eternity inside the
soil world the only way to do that would
be if Gamora is the one to willed the
Infinity Gauntlet during Avengers 4 so
alternate theory the only way they
completely deal with Thanos henceforth
is to have Gamora come out of the soul
world somehow like Ant Man goes into the
quantum realm during ant-man the wasp
what if they travel into the soul stone
to bring her back out but let me know in
the comments how do you think they
rescued Gamora from the soul world and
what do they do with Thanos at the end
because of the end of comic book
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos became part of
the Infinity watch he kind of went from
being a villain
to being more of an antihero type person
so if Thanos doesn't do that at the end
of Avengers 4 they had to do something
to resolve him because I don't think
they bring that character back during
phase 4 phase
five maybe not even during phase six
like however many phases they're gonna
make I think that Thanos isn't going to
come back for a long time but there'll
be a whole bunch more infinity war
posting in the next week obviously
Captain Marvel stuff I'll do a new red
skull video sometime soon after more
people have a chance to see the movie
it's still a little spoilery so I'm not
gonna put him on the thumbnail for this
video even though I probably should but
there's a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on the video click here for my full
review of the movie and click here for
my post credits scene video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]